der französische film beginnt mit einem
schock eine frau verpflichte zurück und
werden ihre eigenen vier wänden gefallen
von einem maskierten täter wird
vergewaltigt und muss man auch damit
zurechtkommen was dieses ereignis die
kartoffeln ihrem leben mit ihrer macht
und wir folgen dieser frau gar nicht
durch ihr leben durch ein sehr komplexes
gut situiertes pariser leben mit vielen
bekannten also ich würde in meinem haus
ich glaube ich wurde vergewaltigt
die gefühlte 40 jeden wie viel in ihrem
leben zurecht kommt mit kultur völlig
außergewöhnliche weise wirkt fast ein
bisschen so als würde sie sich bei ihrem
leben selber zu verlassen das ist ein
großes experiment auch fehlen wir bieten
den erfolg auf bemerkenswerte weise
kühlen und begriffe das macht allen auf
jeder ebene einiger zeit in durch einen
verspannten durch viel auf den reifen
diese qualität selten zu sehen bekommt
für michael patrick infiziert heutigen
verlängern und ach ja ich hatte mit ihm
geprügelt
wir schicken drei wagen um diesen
rechtsstaat zu finden und sie haben sich
mit ihm geprügelt
ich habe ihn in flagranti erwischt er
hat dort in gewicht gehabt und die
hoffnung macht dass ich nicht wieder
wichtigste um staaten mit diesen fällen
ist die kombination zweier
herausragender begabungen des kinos das
eine ist die hauptdarstellerin für bp
auch die das ganze projekt auch
zurückgeht das andere ist der
niederländische für auslösende regie
geführt hat die politik kann als gerade
unterscheidung verbannt wurden
niemand wirklich fotografie tabelle pr
macht es die freude wird das optimum
ich hab mit verdeckten tasche die schule
die einzige partei die psychopathen
gespielt doch nicht der akku sie
zwischen intellekt wollen wir eine kluge
schauspielerin der männer auch beim
letzten tage spielt nicht immer positiv
diese geschichte auf eine sehr
interessante weise einerseits haben wir
es mit einem relativ boxen
gesellschaftsdrama zu tun andererseits
gibt dann doch auch immer wieder zu
andeutungen dass das natürlich von der
politik ernst zu nehmen ist groß und die
gibt wie absolut zu nehmen sie wäre auch
schneller gelaufen und in die verkehrte
interessanten ballack mit großem tempo
mit viel esprit und auch mit vielen
ideen haben wir es mit einem fischerboot
gefährlich der vermehrte gezwungen öl
punkten definitiv gehört ein wirkliches
das wort leistung der geschlecht in
verkehr bringen zusammenhang aber eine
wunderbare kombination von begabungen
und anpöbeln wir uneingeschränkt
empfehlen würden
naja vielleicht deren anna und ich in
einer anderen branche besser aufgehoben
gewesen
vielleicht war kommt nur dank einer
genialen ideen so ein erfolg vielleicht
sind wir nur zwei blinden hühner wie ein
kaum gefunden haben aber für und
tatsache ist dass die spenden
[Musik]